ja schön dass sie hier bei uns sind
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
halt nur deutschland spezial zur
hochwasserkatastrophe im westen
denn das unheil ist noch längst nicht
vorbei sondern im gegenteil die schäden
werden immer größer auch die zahl der
opfer steigt leider weiter an
rheinland-pfalz und nrw erleben und
erleiden eine der größten
unwetterkatastrophen der nachkriegszeit
die flutwelle kam heute am frühen morgen
und riss alles mit erftstadt der
ortsteil blässe die bewohner ahnte
nichts als der damm eines nahe gelegenen
see sprach meter hoch schoss das wasser
durch die engen straßen des ortes und
unterspülte mehrere häuser drei wurden
gleich mitgerissen auch ein teil der
historischen burg wurde zerstört die
anwohner stehen unter schock
ich wohne im bungalow und der großteil
steht im keller und damit ist auch mein
ganzes hab und gut weg innerhalb von
einer halben stunde gekommen sind
wir haben kein gast mehr kein hofberg
keller bis unterkante alles voll aber
letztlich ist es aber natürlich noch so
das leben von menschen das ist das
nummer 1 sondern entscheiden wenn das
wichtigste das haben wir gerettet und
man kann nur hoffen dass viele leben
viele andere menschen das auch geschafft
haben nicht alle bewohner in blessem
haben es geschafft einige sind gestorben
das bestätigt die bezirksregierung in
köln
die rettungskräfte kämpfen sich zur
unglücksstelle durch die ist wegen der
wasser- und schlammmassen nur schwer zu
erreichen
einige bewohner haben zwar hier neben
gerettet aber ihr hab und gut verloren
sie stehen vor dem nichts und es geht
noch weiter die erft ist eigentlich ein
beschauliches flüsschen aber jetzt ist
hier ein reißender strom der immer noch
alles mit sich reißt etwa 20 kilometer
vom blessem entfernt ist die lage an der
steinbachtalsperre weiter brisant der
damm ist stark beschädigt und instabil
niemand weiß ob er hält eine meter hohe
flutwelle droht auch hier alles zu
zerstören daher wurden die menschen die
in orten unterhalb der talsperre leben
evakuiert viele sind jetzt den
heimerzheim in einer notunterkunft
gestrandet die meisten haben alles
verloren
wir haben gekämpft bis zum 12
da haben die schon abgeschaltet haben
was man einmal versucht aber dann meinen
sohn ging in den garten papa papa komm
ganz schön ist es da ich habe da willst
du mich verarschen ich bin rausgerannt
die wohnzimmertür diesem weg ich weiß
nicht wo diese msc molitor ist weg ich
weiß jetzt wo die ist keine ahnung ich
hab ich schon nicht gefunden
total krass und überall dieser schlamm
dieses dreckige heizöl
das stinkt du kannst du vielleicht fünf
minuten da drin aushalten zehn minuten
durften bereiten wir haben rausgeholt
was wir konnten medikamente für meine
frau sachen zum anziehen
aber wenn du das haus betritt du christ
einen schlag über 1000 menschen waren
hier zeitweise untergebracht viel arbeit
für die helfer und es kommen immer noch
neue menschen nach ich habe den eindruck
dass alle sehr gefasst sind
trotz der schweren lage in der sich
jetzt die menschen und die region hier
befinden also alle sind sehr bemühte
dafür zu sorgen dass das ganze gut
funktioniert und von daher haben wir
auch ja sagen also eine alle stimmung
gutes insgesamt sind 23 kommunen in nrw
von den überschwemmungen betroffen
ministerpräsident laschet ging daher am
mittag vor die presse wir werden häuser
reparieren brücken wieder aufbauen
verkehrswege wieder instand setzen
aber die menschen leben die in den
fluten verloren gegangen sind sind
unersetzbar
die nordrhein westfalen nahmen nach
jetzigem stand mindestens 43 menschen
durch diese katastrophe ihr leben
verloren es steht zu befürchten dass es
noch mehr werden
in heimerzheim wurde auch ein
kindergarten zu einer notunterkunft
umfunktioniert zahlreiche nachbarn
kommen und spenden kleidung spielzeug
und dinge für den täglichen bedarf ein
lichtblick in dieser schweren zeit ja
und ein weiterer lichtblick könnte sein
in dieser so schweren zeit dass der damm
der steinbachtalsperre im kreis
euskirchen hält das ist noch nicht
sicher aber es heißt doch immer noch
noch ralph goldmann der in einen
nachbarort steht liebe zuschauer also
man sieht da den da ich nicht und das
was da alles schon überschwemmt ist weil
das netz dort besser ist wo sie stehen
da ist die verbindung stabiler
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass der
damen der steinbachtalsperre doch noch
brechen könnte ja die gefahr ist
natürlich immer noch da aber wir hören
jetzt meldungen dass
ist ein bisschen stabiler sein soll als
man vorher befürchtet hatte es hieß es
hätten sich tiefe furchen im damm
gebildet ein drohnen überflug hat aber
offenbar gezeigt dass keine tiefen risse
zu sehen sind man hat darauf kräftig
wasser dort abgepumpt man muss natürlich
druck von diesen damen nehmen und bis
jetzt hält er zumindest und das ist auch
das oberste ziel dort unten
dass nicht noch mehr wasser
unkontrolliert hierdurch die kleinen
flüsse läuft und noch mehr häuser
überschwemmt werden
und zur sicherheit hat man ja die
einwohner in der umliegenden umgebung
evakuiert sind denn alle einwohner
inzwischen wirklich auch in sicherheit
ja also das sieht ganz danach aus als
4500 menschen sind in sicherheit
gebracht worden
sie dürfen auch ihre häuser im moment
jedenfalls nicht betreten
sie sind in notunterkünften
untergebracht worden wir haben das
ansatzweise schon im beitrag gesehen 700
menschen sind in einer turnhalle in
heimerzheim etwa zehn kilometer von hier
untergebracht worden da sind technisches
hilfswerk malteser rotes kreuz die
bundespolizei und sorgt für essen ja
dort haben sie eine notunterkunft mit
feldbetten in einer turnhalle
wir hatten die gelegenheit mit einigen
von ihnen zu sprechen und wir hätten uns
mal ganz kurz an was sie zu sagen hatten
also nicht wir haben um ein halb sieben
schon angefangen da kam schon das wasser
hoch das grundwasser ins haus gelaufen
wir haben gekämpft bis zum 12 da haben
die schon abgeschaltet was man einmal
versucht aber dann meinen sohn ging in
den garten papa papa komm ganz schön ist
es da ich habe gerade lässt du mich
verarschen ich bin raus gerannt und habe
ich schon den assist gestanden bin ich
drauf andrea wir müssen wir haben
verloren wir müssen gehen jetzt ist es
im garten da kamen die auch schon rein
erste welle da haben wir den keller leer
pumpen können
und er war dann auch schon trocken
und
dann kam ihr zweiter welle dann stehe
ich habe wieder das was man es ging also
später ist er ist der keller voll und
dann auch das haus unten und da renault
dieses stockwerken ist im grunde alles
was oft kein haus steht noch ja aber es
hat ein altes fachwerkhaus aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert was jetzt nicht
wieder mit den wänden es wieder mit mit
dem ton ist und mit dem leben und alles
drum und dran katastrophe also mal
ausgemistet was das für die kinder jetzt
was auf die schnellere sortiert werden
kann
ja
hier sind wir sind trocken geblieben
haben glück gehabt wir versuchen heute
zu helfen wo wir helfen können
mit helfen wo man helfen kann das tun ja
auch sehr viele ralf wie erleben sie die
hilfsbereitschaft bei ihnen vor ort
von diesen beispielen die wir eben da
gesehen haben gibt es unendlich viele
also gerade auch in den bereich um die
notunterkünfte sind da sind immer wieder
menschen vor gefahren die
kleidungsstücke bringen im kindergarten
haben wir gesehen dass windeln zum
beispiel gebracht werden oder
babynahrung solche dinge also die
hilfsbereitschaft ist sehr sehr groß die
solidarität und die menschen ist sehr
sehr groß ich habe ein schild in einem
fenster gesehen ein großes dastand
coffee to go for free toiletten for free
also wer da mal ein café haben wollte
der konnte einfach so vorbeikommen
ein mann hat mir gesagt was wir hier
überhaupt nicht gebrauchen können das
sind katastrophen touristen denn das
gibt es auch die machen hier mit ihren
smartphones videos und fotos und der
mann sagte zu mir sie können gerne
kommen aber dann sollen sie helfen und
dann sollen sie vor allem bautrockner
mitbringen weil das ist das was am
nötigsten gebraucht wird wenn die leute
dann irgendwann in ihre häuser wieder
zurückkehren können und davon braucht
dann sicherlich sehr sehr viele vielen
dank ralph goldmann nach euskirchen
euskirchen sowie es ausgesprochen und
wir schauen jetzt weiter nach erftstadt
südlich von köln es ist ein
zusammenschluss mehrerer orte benannt
nach diesem kleinen fluss erft doch der
ist zu einem reißenden strom geworden
der sich seinen weg gebahnt wie er will
und auch mitreißt was ihnen im wege
steht da ist also das passiert was man
eben noch verhindern konnte bisher
alexander hettich der ist unser reporter
dort in dem katastrophengebiet alexander
wie kommen denn die rettungskräfte voran
denn noch immer gelten bei ihnen ja
menschen als vermisst
in der gesamten region wurden zum
letzten 19 personen als vermisst
gemeldet das bezieht sich allerdings
nicht nur auf den ostteil blessing an
dem ich gespielt sondern auch auf die
region drumherum das ist ja auch die
autobahn überschwemmt auch dort sind
fahrzeuge steckengeblieben
also es sind nach wie vor sind such
aktionen nötig wenn man sich einen blick
auf das haus hinter mir wirft das
eingestürzt ist da kann man so ein
bisschen erahnen wie groß die
katastrophe ist wenn man an diesen
krater steht an dem ich eben gestanden
habe und dieses runterrutschen autos
sieht die trümmer der häuser dann ist
das extrem beklemmend und man kann sich
vorstellen dass die behörden gar nicht
wissen können zu diesem zeitpunkt wie
viele opfer es gegeben hat für den rest
des ortes heißt es jetzt erst mal
ungewissheit können die häuser stehen
bleiben was ist mit der statik
aufräumarbeiten sind nötig habe mit
einer anwohnerin hier gerade gesprochen
das ist michael bollig die hier pferde
in einem gutshof stehen hat frau wollte
das gestern abend alles miterlebt eine
flutwelle quer durch den ort wie sah das
aus wie haben sie das erlebt also am
anfang war das noch relativ normal aber
man musste wirklich feststellen dass es
relativ schnell so viel wasser meisten
hier kommen dass wir wirklich schnell
gehandelt haben und haben wirklich
innerhalb kürzester zeit alle hebel in
bewegung gesetzt um die ganzen pferde
evakuiert der teil alles was hier unten
ist war trocken alles oberhalb ging noch
somit haben wir wirklich gedacht okay
aber ins trockene und das so schnell wie
möglich wann haben sie gemerkt das wird
noch schlimmer es geht hier um
menschenleben es sind häuser abgerutscht
eigentlich ziemlich schnell weil wenn
man die bilder aus den umliegenden
regieren gesehen hat wie schnell das
wasser tatsächlich ihren vormarsch macht
dass es teilweise zehn minuten braucht
bis man knie über knietief im wasser
steht haben wir nicht lange gefackelt
und haben eigentlich sofort gehandelt
weil wir gedacht haben
das artet hier aus wie gehen die
menschen damit um wir behalten uns hier
sehr zurück ist sind einige menschen
sieht man an dass sie das noch gar nicht
wirklich fassen können
wie geht er damit um dass hier
möglicherweise einige personen aus dem
leben gerissen wurden also ich glaube
nach außen hin wirkt das erst mal alles
ist total unreal braucht man auch
wirklich noch zeit bis man das wirklich
ganze realisiert hat ich glaube tief
innen und so geht's uns allen supernase
ziemlich nervenaufreibend zwar alle so
als wäre es ganz cool aber ich glaube
innerlich wird man noch sehen hinterher
dass das richtige ausmaße nimmt auch mit
selber einem und das
projekt 1 fürs leben definitiv das ist
dank ihnen alles gute
ja die behörden suchen weiter schauen
weiter was hier wirklich passiert ist
die hilfskräfte haben wirklich alles
gegeben feuerwehrleute thw sind hier im
einsatz also schon eine beeindruckende
leistung die leute helfen sich auch
gegenseitig aber das wird hier noch
wochen und monate dauern bis hier ein
wenig ruhe eingekehrt ist vielen dank
nach erftstadt die bilder sind wirklich
verheerend danke dass sie uns das so
eindrücklich geschildert haben und auch
immer mit der nötigen distanz in bezug
auf die menschen die es eben betrifft in
diesen tagen und monaten von dort liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer kommen wir
weiter nach rheinland pfalz das nachbar
bundesland das er ebenfalls mit voller
wucht von dem hochwasser getroffen wurde
mehr als 60 menschen mussten bisher
schon ihr leben lassen in dieser
verheerenden katastrophe und so
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer vorhin
das leid nimmt weiter zu denn es wird
befürchtet dass noch weitere opfer dazu
kommen sobald das wasser zurückgeht
sinzig eine weitere traurige nachricht
aus diesem hochwasser drama hier sind in
der nacht zum donnerstag zwölf menschen
mit behinderung in den fluten umgekommen
wir haben einander mehr oder weniger
retten können weil der ist raus wir
wissen nicht warum man draußen war der
hin- an der wand hängt an der wand und
schreie und hat gerufen ich will nicht
sterben hilfe ich kann die schwimmen und
so weiter und er ist gerettet worden und
die anderen halt nicht die waren
eingeschlossen der eifelort schuld
dutzende häuser sind von den
wassermassen beschädigt für die 700
einwohner ist nichts mehr so wie vorher
der schock sitzt tief im minutentakt
kann man wirklich sagen minutentakt zehn
zentimeter mehr
mein schwager hat noch versucht hier
autos zu retten ist noch gerade
herausgekommen ist mein auto runter
geschwemmt worden hat dass da noch
gerade bei uns in die einfahrt geparkt
ja und dann war auch fast nichts mehr zu
machen
vor allen dingen ist kein strom kein
wasser da ist nichts mehr da kein
telefon kein handy nichts geht mehr
also die laut brecht allein im kreis
ahrweiler werden noch 1300 menschen
vermisst
viele sind aber wahrscheinlich einfach
nicht erreichbar
handynetz ist weiterhin schlecht und die
zahl der toten in rheinland-pfalz steigt
weiter an
das leid nimmt zu im rheinland pfalz und
unsere gedanken sind fest bei den
menschen die alles verloren haben wir
haben zur stunde 60 tote zu beklagen
und es ist zu befürchten dass die zahl
noch weiter ansteigen wird
die rettungskräfte am limit wie hier in
dernau die bundeswehr es mit dem einsatz
sie transportiert noch leichen ab
verstärkungen ist unterwegs sagt der
innenminister von rheinland-pfalz wir
gegen hubschrauber wir kriegen
bergepanzer wir kriegen schweres
material telefonieren mit meinen
kollegen innenministern die uns alles
zur verfügung stellen was wir kriegen
können wir sind nach wie vor mit den
hubschraubern im einsatz um menschen von
dächern teilweise sogar wirklich aus
bäumen zu retten
die fluten haben alles mitgerissen
häuser zerstört das ausmaß der
katastrophe ist gewaltig überall nur
schlamm
auch der pegel der mosel stieg in der
nacht noch an
die feuerwehr war mit schlauchbooten im
einsatz um eingeschlossenen bewohnern zu
helfen
zurück in sinzig die bürger packen
derweil mit an um den ort von den
schlamassel zu befreien
mitten in der korona pandemie sind sie
auf diese weitere tragödie kaum
vorbereitet sind sich die stadt mit den
meisten kohler toten wir hatten in
altersheimen zu beginn der deckung
es sind viele männer die meisten im
ganzen kreisgebiet hier aus sind sich
gestorben sind
das ist schon tragisch muss ich sagen
die gemeinschaft ist man nicht sicher
ist in sicherheit konnten nicht alle
bewohner rechtzeitig gebracht werden die
wassermassen drangen zu rasant in die
behinderten einrichtung des vereins
lebenshilfe ein
die bewohner hatten keine chance mehr
wie so vieles in diesen tagen aus den
betroffenen gebieten machen auch diese
nachrichten aus sind sich einfach nur
tief tief betroffen
diese zwölf menschen mit behinderung die
dort in dieser einrichtung ertrunken
sind unsere reporterin angela wepper die
ist dort für uns angela können sie schon
näheres dazu sagen wie es zu dieser
tragödie kommen konnte ja zunächst
einmal möchte ich sagen dass hier die
stimmung in der nachbarschaft der
lebenshilfe sehr sehr bedrückt ist man
könnte die bewohner hier man ist sich
begegnet man hat ein schwätzchen
gehalten man hat geredet miteinander und
jetzt diese tragödie
die menschen hier sind offensichtlich in
der nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag
hier von der flutwelle völlig überrascht
worden und zwar im schlaf sie haben hier
wie sie uns erzählt haben in der straße
keine sirenen und keine
lautsprecherdurchsagen gehört die
feuerwehr wollte hier die bewohner des
lebenshilfe noch in der nacht evakuieren
aber da war es offensichtlich schon zu
spät der nachtdienst der hier die
betreuung hatte wollte die bewohner
wecken aber in der zeit ist die
flutwelle schon so schnell gestiegen
innerhalb von minuten ist das wasser das
sieht man hier auch an dem haus an der
hauswand bis über das erdgeschoss
gestiegen hat die bewohner in ihren
zimmern eingeschlossen und zwölf
bewohner mussten leider ertrinken
einer konnte sich retten konnte sich
nach draußen retten
der hat dann um hilfe gerufen die
nachbarn haben das gehört und haben ihn
ermutigt sich an irgendein baum
festzuklammern so lange bis hilfe kommt
das hat dann wirklich für den relativ
lange gedauert
ein feuerwehrboot hat ihn dann retten
können
es ist jetzt hier für viel die anderen
bewohner kamen natürlich eben die hilfe
leider zu spät warum die menschen nicht
evakuiert werden konnten das ist jetzt
hier die große frage aber das ist
natürlich auch noch sache der
untersuchungen die hier laufen dafür ist
es jetzt noch zu früh
vielleicht können sie alternativ und das
verstehen wir natürlich auch dass man da
noch gar nichts zu sagen kann
alternativ ganz kurz noch mal darauf
eingehen wie die überlebenden bewohner
und auch die mitarbeiter jetzt betreut
werden psychologisch körperlich also die
die überlebt haben jetzt konnten hier
einige gerettet werden aus den oberen
stockwerken
die sind von der stadt sinzig in den
umliegenden hotels untergebracht worden
da hat man ein zimmer angemietet und sie
und die angehörigen werden natürlich
psychologisch betreute betreut
es geht ihnen soweit man das jetzt in
dieser situation sagen kann so weit so
gut aber die menschen hier in sind sich
sind natürlich unheimlich traurig und
wir mit vielen dank angela partner sind
sich im landkreis ahrweiler ja und
ebenfalls dort im landkreis ahrweiler
befindet sich ein ort der bereits
gestern extrem heftig von dem hochwasser
getroffen wurde
sie erinnern sich wahrscheinlich schuld
heißt der und heute da wird das ausmaß
der schäden erst so richtig deutlich
dort unser reporter botticelli an der
ist für uns in schuld und bobby einer
der einwohner hat gemeint das ist wie im
krieg hier
wie beschreiben sie persönlich die
aktuelle lage vor ort
wer dieser vergleich kriegsgebiet ist
natürlich ein sehr harter vergleich
tatsächlich muss ich aber sagen
als wir das erste mal hier angekommen
sind und uns dieses ausmaß der
zerstörungen angeschaut haben
da ging es nicht nur mir sondern dem
gesamten team so dass uns genau dieser
vergleich eingefallen ist es sieht
tatsächlich aus wie im krieg gebiet
mehrere häuser sind schlichtweg weg die
mal hier hinter mir standen die sind
nicht mehr da autos liegen auf dem dach
unter geröll begraben sind weggerissen
worden
ob das jetzt eine flutwelle gewesen ist
oder eine explosion kann man glaube ich
als außenstehender wenn man einfach nur
drauf schaut gar nicht beurteilen aber
wir wissen es ja das sind unglaubliche
wassermassen die hier durch den ort
geflossen sind durch schuld die
unglaublich viel mitgerissen haben eine
riesige zerstörungskraft entfaltet haben
insofern ist dieser vergleich zum
kriegsgebiet in diesem fall durchaus
gerechtfertigt 700 einwohner so in etwa
hat der ort schuld wie geht es den
menschen dort
ja da muss man natürlich sagen es sind
nicht alle so schwer getroffen worden
wie diejenigen die ihre häuser und
wohnungen komplett verloren haben es
gibt auch einige die hier oberhalb der
des flusses wohnen der a- und die
dementsprechend noch ganz gut davon
gekommen sind nächstes nichtsdestotrotz
bei denen ist die betroffenheit auch
sehr groß es geht um die nachbarn es ist
ein kleiner ort sagt nicht gerade 700
menschen da kennt man sich und man weiß
auch wenn es besonders schwer getroffen
hat und dann gibt es eben die die jetzt
überhaupt nichts mehr haben deren häuser
weg sind deren wohnungen weg sind deren
habseligkeiten auch weg sind da war ein
ganz vorherrschendes gefühl auch schon
gestern das bis heute in den tag hinein
gewirkt hat der schock der schock
darüber was passiert ist das wasser kam
man konnte sich nicht davor in
sicherheit bringen
menschen die sich verschanzt haben und
erst später gerettet werden konnten
also diese verzweiflung und
hilflosigkeit der shop auf der einen
seite und jetzt heute sicher diese
erkenntnis die einsätze einen tag später
was ist da eigentlich passiert nachdem
so das adrenalin wahrscheinlich den
körper auch verlässt und man sieht
schlichtweg ganz viele menschen die hier
auf und ab gehen die immer mal wieder
versuchen ins gebiet reinzukommen sachen
vielleicht noch zu retten
mit einer ganz großen verzweiflung im
gesicht mit tränen in den augen
das ist etwas was heute einen ganz
bleibender eindruck ist diese tiefe
enttäuschung und verzweiflung ja gerade
wieder im hintergrund bei ihnen zu
erkennen jemand der da in den trümmern
steht ein wort noch zu den
rettungsarbeiten ich habe gehört keiner
wird zumindest mehr vermisst können sie
das verändert zum ende der live-schalte
bestätigen
tatsächlich ist das so das hat uns die
einsatzleitung heute auch noch mal
bestätigt alle menschen die hier mal
vermisst waren deren verbleib ist
sozusagen geklärt es wird ja keiner
vermisst tatsächlich nach jetzigem stand
ist es auch so dass trotz dieser enormen
zerstörung hier in schuld niemand
gestorben ist zum jetzigen stand und das
ist eine gute nachricht unter den vielen
schlechten und für die sind wir gerade
in diesen tagen sehr sehr dankbar vielen
dank bobby nach schuld ja und wenn wir
etwas mehr als 100 autokilometer in
richtung süden fahren dann landen wir in
trier und auch diese region rund um die
älteste stadt deutschlands ist nicht vom
hochwasser verschont geblieben
viele häuser mussten auch hier evakuiert
werden darunter ein krankenhaus und ein
seniorenheim mehrere hundert menschen
sind davon betroffen
und auch in den nächsten tagen werden
sie wohl nicht zurückkehren können und
sind jetzt erstmal in notunterkünften
untergebracht wie zum beispiel in
turnhallen überflutete orte zerstörte
existenzen
häuser werden evakuiert anwohner in
sicherheit gebracht
auch die patienten eines krankenhauses
einige unmittelbar nach ihrer op kurze
zeit später läuft die klinik voll die
schäden nicht zu beziffern
der ausnahmezustand hält an
[Musik]
in dieser schule in trier sind
zahlreiche hauseigentümer und mieter nun
untergebracht
die spenden und hilfsbereitschaft ist
groß fast alle kennen irgend jemanden
der von der katastrophe betroffen ist
ein etwa wurde
freunde verwandte von mir in ehrang die
sind evakuiert wurden meine eltern ohne
gott sei dank auf dem berg aber das ist
einfach schrecklich man kann es nicht
anders sagen man kann nur will keinem mb
stehen ein bisschen was man machen kann
wenn aufgerufen wird bringt was vorbei
was zu essen paar warme decken ist ja
das problem dringend benötigt
lebensmittel kleidung hygieneartikel und
vor allem emotionale unterstützung in
dieser ausnahmesituation auch bei
roswitha temmels ging alles ganz schnell
gestern ich habe wichtige papiere zu
hause liegen gelassen
ja weil wir haben gar keine wäsche
eingepackt wie wir kamen gar nicht mehr
dazu war wie gesagt habe vier kinder
dabei mein mann und mein sohn ist halt
krank
ja so nun gegen halt man kann gar nicht
denken nicht ganz alles sagen also wir
haben nichts eingepackt richtig war
wieder medikamente noch sonst irgendwas
wird ist alles in der wohnung und so gut
aussieht ist unsere erste etage
vollgelaufen
wir hatten vor zwei jahren schon mal in
eine tragödie wohnungsbrand da muss man
immer von vorne anfangen und jetzt wie
gesagt deshalb sehr sehr schwierig an
ein zurück in die häuser ist vorerst
noch nicht zu denken und unsere
reporterin verena garrett die hat mit
vielen menschen gesprochen die heute
nacht wirklich auch in einer
notunterkunft waren was ist ihnen verena
aus diesen vielen gesprächen mit den
betroffenen ganz besonders hängen
geblieben
vor allem wegen jetzt erstmal hängen
geblieben dass die leute froh sind dass
sie überhaupt da raus geschafft haben
wir haben wie gesagt vielen vielen
menschen dort gesprochen und die meisten
haben uns erzählt sie hatten überhaupt
keine zeit überhaupt nachzudenken was
sie einpacken was sie mitnehmen wollen
das waren und welche kleinigkeiten
einfach in der tasche geworfen und dann
mussten sie raus aus dem haus
sie waren sehr glücklich dass sie es
geschafft haben ihre
dass tiere zu retten und ja sie haben
jetzt alle nacht in dieser notunterkunft
verbracht das war ein schulzentrum und
sie haben sich da auch sehr gut versorgt
gefühlt die spendenbereitschaft war sehr
groß da waren menschen kleidung
vorbeigebracht tierfutter spiele für die
kinder also da war schon auch sehr viel
dabei und die menschen haben waren da
auch sehr froh darüber
jetzt mussten sie noch einmal umziehen
heute wurden sie in wohnungen in den
umliegenden ortschaften gebracht sie
wurden in einer alten kaserne
untergebracht und auch dort müssen sie
jetzt ein paar tage bleiben
und eigentlich wollen sie nur zurück in
ihre häuser das haben natürlich auch
alle gesagt also sie wollen zurück dahin
wo sie wohnen und wo sie leben und
wollen da sauber machen weil mir ist der
oberbürgermeister von trier wolfram
leibe
herr leibe wo ist denn das problem das
wasser ist jetzt zurückgegangen ein paar
menschen können da anscheinend ja auch
schon ein bisschen putzen warum geht das
nicht warum können die menschen nicht
zurück
je nach straße wie tief die straße liegt
stehen teilweise eben noch auch im
erdgeschoss ein meter wasser und dieses
wasser ist vermischt mit heizöl und
deshalb muss man jetzt genau hingucken
das große die große frage ist wir haben
häuser die sind 200 jahre alt wurden die
fundamente unterspült und deshalb muss
eine begehung mit statikern gemacht
werden wir hatten ein großes großes
glück dass keine menschen verletzt oder
getötet worden sind und ich möchte jetzt
nicht dass die menschen die ihre häuser
gehen und verletzten sich weil irgendwas
zusammenbricht gibt es da dann schon
irgendeinen zeitraum worauf können sich
die leute einstellen sie wissen ich
meine sie mangels einer nacht in der
schule
jetzt sind sie wieder woanders sie haben
eigentlich nicht sie wollen ihre sachen
worauf können wie sich dann einstellen
kann man das schon sagen von 1.600 die
wir evakuiert haben haben wir jetzt noch
130 140 in der übergangslösung das heißt
viele sind schon dabei ihre häuser
wieder aufzubauen zu sanieren und und
und also ist unglaublich nachbarn helfen
sich auch schon gegenseitig aber für
einige häuser haben wir angefangen mit
statikern jetzt zu begehen und wir
hoffen dass wir in den nächsten zwei
tagen zumindest eine augen sicht name
machen können damit die statiker von
außen sagen können das ist okay oder
nicht okay das ist keine perfekte
prüfung aber wir möchten dass die
menschen sehr schnell wieder in ihre
häuser zurück gehen können
das ist aber auch ein langer prozess wir
haben gerade schon die
nachbarschaftshilfe angesprochen
die angewiesen sind die menschen darauf
dass sie sich gegenseitig helfen
wir haben alle bilder da steht das
wasser bis zu zwei meter im erdgeschoss
es ist alles kaputt im keller
heizungsanlage möbel und das muss raus
getragen werden und da braucht man
unterstützung von nachbarn also ist es
noch ein langer prozess
das stimmt und damit erstmal vielen dank
verena gerät nach trier und auch jeden
wolf vom leib und all ihren helferinnen
und helfern alles gute und tolle
nachbarschaftshilfe auch da in ihrem
gebiet ja und so nah unsere
reporterinnen wirena gerade und reporter
wie vorhin an den menschen sind an den
unglücksorten die ganze dramatik dieser
katastrophe die momente in denen die
flut plötzlich kommt die wird vor allem
dann umso greifbarer wenn man die handy
videos der augenzeugen sieht immer mehr
dramatische amateuraufnahmen aus den
katastrophengebieten mitten in den
fluten treibt ein mensch es ist ein
feuerwehrmann der von der strömung
mitgerissen wurde
trotz der großen gefahr ziehen ihn
mutige anwohner mit vereinten kräften an
land diese aufnahmen stammen aus altena
in nordrhein westfalen
welche kraft die strömung hat zeigen
diese amateuraufnahmen aus mülheim an
der ruhr wo ein tonnenschweres
fahrgastschiff mit gerissen und zerstört
wird
die stadt altena in nordrhein westfalen
hat es hart getroffen
auch anwohner francesco dokumentiert die
lage mit seinem handy
da wo die straße war ist einfach nichts
mehr es ist einfach unfassbar
rettungsfahrzeuge beschädigt es sieht
hier aus wie nach dem krieg also das ist
noch das was vom rettungsfahrzeug übrig
geblieben ist wie man sehen kann
die leute sind an ihre grenzen überall
geht abgepumpt überall wird geschrubbt
golfen hilfe brauchen auch die menschen
in stolberg in nordrhein westfalen
diese amateuraufnahmen ging gerade um
die welt eine person hängt am
feuerwehrauto und wird von den rettern
in letzter minute ins fahrzeug gezogen
stolberg die gleiche straße am tag
danach
viele menschen haben noch keinen strom
können wegen leerer handyakku sie ihre
angehörigen nicht erreichen
die erste bestandsaufnahme in ihren
zerstörten häusern
für die meisten ein schock
[Musik]
hier ist alles einfach nur kaputt das
jahrhunderthochwasser hat überall
deutliche spuren hinterlassen
wichtig dass er schnell wieder aufgebaut
wird
aber es ist hier einfach wahnsinn ich
weiß nicht ob wir das alles führen
könnte
also man kann sich an diesen anblick
einfach überhaupt gar nicht verarbeiten
ehrlich gesagt die leute sind dabei hier
alle auf der straße hier wird überall
wollten
aber hier ist einfach unglaublich viel
zerstört ich glaube plötzlich jetzt noch
gar nicht absehen was darauf die leute
noch zu kommen und auch viele tiere sind
durch die flut völlig verängstigt
[Musik]
für besitzer die ihre tiere zu retten
konnten aber nun nicht wissen wohin
bietet dieser verein in zülpich in
nordrhein-westfalen hilfe an
22 pferde und drei schweine haben sie
bereits aufgenommen
wir haben noch platz wir können noch
tiere aufnehmen das ist schon einiges
angekommen
das größte problem ist dass die meisten
gar nicht zu uns durch kommen aufgrund
der wassermassen wer es irgendwie
schafft zu uns zu kommen also ihr seid
alle herzlich willkommen
es sind die menschen von nebenan die mit
ihren handykameras die bilder
festgehalten haben die für uns alle noch
unbegreiflich sind ja und einer der
gründe warum dieses unbegreifliche
geschehen ist und der viele regen zu so
vielen stellen geführt hat das hat auch
etwas mit der sogenannten
flächenversiegelung zu tun oder mal ganz
einfach formuliert zu viel beton zu
wenig natürlich herde extremwetter in
deutschland doch die zerstörerischen
wassermassen sie sind nur der auslöser
der katastrophe
die eigentliche ursache liegt anderswo
seit jahrzehnten bereitet die
flächenversiegelung dem hochwasser den
weg in deutschland werden täglich circa
56 hektar als siedlungs und
verkehrsflächen neu ausgewiesen um kein
bauland zu verschenken lassen gemeinden
die uferbereiche einfach zubetonieren
asphalt und beton können aber kein
wasser aufnehmen
so holt sich das wasser bei starkregen
den platz zurück den der mensch im einst
genommen hat ein weiteres problem mehr
als 90 prozent der deutschen flüsse und
bäche sind über weite strecken begradigt
eingeengt und verlaufen in rohren
sobald das wasser in ein unnatürliches
flussbett gezwängt wird fließt es
schneller
flussbegradigungen werden vor allem
durchgeführt um flächen für die
landwirtschaft zu gewinnen aber auch um
ein gewässer für die schifffahrt zu
nutzen
schließlich leitet auch die zerstörung
der auenlandschaft den überschwemmungen
vorschub rund 80 prozent der natürliche
überflutungsflächen gingen bisher in
deutschland verloren natürliche
überflutungsflächen auch retentionsräume
genannt sind ein wichtiger schutz vor
extremen hochwasser wie ein schwamm
speichern sie das nass zubetoniert
begradigt verbaut
die fehlentwicklungen der letzten jahre
haben dazu geführt dass die bäche und
flüsse ihre bedeutung für die umwelt
verloren haben und so fordern experten
eindringlich ein neues wassermanagement
ein hoffnungsschimmer nein viel mehr
noch als ein hoffnungsschimmer in diesen
tagen voller erschütternde nachrichten
das ist die außerordentliche
hilfsbereitschaft der menschen in den
betroffenen gebieten und auch sie können
unterstützen und zwar über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf hochwasser deutschland die
kontonummer finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite
8 190 und jetzt geht's hier weiter mit
leute heute die niederländische
königsfamilie die posiert professionell
und auch traditionelle form sommerurlaub
für die fotografen obwohl es in ihnen
drin ganz anders aussah und die herzen
schwer waren warum das erfahren sie hier
in nur wenigen sekunden